Well, good afternoon, thank you for
participating in this videoconference, and
so today we begin the talk about
environmental enrichment in laboratory mice,
using especially studying the
effects on reproductive physiology
and postnatal development in mice.
My name is Marina Ponzio.
work I am a CONICET researcher
and professor of the chair of
human physiology at the Faculty of
Medical Sciences at the University of Córdoba in
Argentina, which is where we developed
this research work
that lasted approximately two years.
What we
know about environmental enrichment is
any change made to an
animal's housing that should
increase the frequency and diversity
of positive natural behaviors,
further reduce the occurrence of
abnormal behaviors, and increase
the ability of these individuals to
adapt to the c  Captivity conditions
and enrichment methods for
laboratory rodents
generally described in the bibliography are
quite variable, although in general they
can include the addition of
material for the construction of nests,
what is called the nib in English, such
as making strips of paper towels.  of
tissue paper the paper of your cotton wool
of wood or of various materials for
the construction of some type of nest
can be an enrichment provided
by different structures that can be
added to the housing box,
such as a special box for
the realization  from a nest in
cardboard rolls pvc tubes climbing bars
for example partitions tunnels and many
other features
and other options for example to
enrich the environment of
laboratory animals include also options
for locomotion
the provision of increased space
what is  which is regularly used
in
and some other resource by e  example an
exercise wheel perhaps a
larger room
a social grouping hardness of the
special food pellets that is to say
there are many options that are being
used to achieve
environmental enrichment in
mice laboratory mice
the successful paradigms support the
general notion that the  Expansion
of options for an animal to express
species-specific behaviors
can positively impact
both psychological and physiological animal welfare. It
has been that each species evolves to
maximize its chances of survival.
Behaviors without data
logically favor homeostasis and
physical health.
this is how I follow the enrichment options
can increase the mental health,
let's say psychological, of an individual by
providing instruments or actions
that favor behaviors and
instinctive preferences in general and
that would otherwise be
abnormally expressed, however the use of
or  Static objects and structures can
sometimes cause an effect of
unwanted behavioral responses in
general, objects or items that are
added that animals can alter
by themselves according to their needs and
one of these are the
most effective types of enrichment when it comes
to  then trigger
new and interactive positive responses, which are
the ones that interest us
well. One small thing that I forgot to
tell you at the last minute is that
I am going to give my talk and that at the end of
it I am going to read
all the questions that you have sent me in the
meantime with
I'll be happy to answer them by
the end of this presentation.
Well then, the objectives of our
work were taking into account that
although there is a growing amount of
evidence indicating that
environmental enrichment facilitates
both development and behavior in
laboratory mice.  in reality very
few studies have been conducted to
demonstrate its impact  fact on the
reproductive physiology of animals, that is to say,
both in males and females, and the
evidence indicates the importance of
environmental complexity for
reproduction,
without a doubt, and because it is because by
promoting optimal neuroendocrine performance
that is required for an
adequate response, both physiological
and  behavioral these individuals
, however, there are few studies
carried out on what is the impact of
environmental enrichment on
reproductive physiology if there are
published works regarding, for example,
very basic basic questions of what
is reproductive physiology or
reproductive performance, in reality, which
is the  number of pups the number of
births that a couple can have the
survival of these pups and so on, but
reproductive physiology in general
implies a much deeper knowledge
of all that is reproductive aspects
and that was then our
idea and ultimately the objective  general
was to evaluate  then the modifications
produced by an enriched environment
on reproductive physiology and
postnatal development also in
sweet albino mice, which was the strain
that we use and the strain that
we use in general in our
laboratory, which is a laboratory
specifically dedicated to the study of
reproductive physiology
of laboratory animals in my specialty
I am also a member of the
care and use committee for
laboratory animals therefore we were very interested in
this topic and that is how
we started it all developing
well as part of the
food materials we are going to start talking
about animals  that we use and their
housing
the houses we use the
housing boxes we use standard
opaque green houses as you can see in
the photographs since it was the color that
we had read in the bibliography
that has less impact on the
animals or in reality than these
animals of  pref laboratories  They want or
have a greater preference for
green or yellow boxes so well
we used green houses
well the boxes had
standard dimensions macro type long 1 of 30
centimeters long by height and
14 wide
sorry if 14 wide we use
shavings as substrate  of wood
commercial food in pellets of the cargil brand
from here in Argentina and water that was
provided haz libitum
as enrichment we used
pvc tubes and paper disintegrated into strips
and the animals we used both male
and female albino mouse suite as
name previously and these were
Animals housed in cages
in groups of five individuals and no more
in each cage. We are going to see that there are
some slightly special conditions
that we are going to see later.
So, to summarize the experimental design a bit,
we had two
large experiments. I am going to describe them
now.  So the number one experiment
in which we use rearing to
weaning is 21 days of  e age that were
again housed in groups of 5
individuals and subjected to the following
treatments
on the one hand we carried out the treatment and
control
in which the animals were
kept under standard laboratory control conditions
from the day of birth
in this case until the  At the end of the
experiment
we used a second group that were
animals enriched from weaning,
that is, that is why they are marked sorry, it
is marked in purple the moment
in which
the enrichment was added to the cage
where these individuals were housed,
that is, here on day 21  which is the day
of weaning and these animals
were then enriched with the conditions
that we named above
sell weaning until sweet and
until the end of the experiment
and a third group of animals was
a group of 21 day old animals
that were raised until  their adulthood
at 60 days yes and at that moment when
the animals were adults
the  enrichment until the day of the
end of the experiment this
was done to somehow discriminate
the ability of a mother
to take care of her pups when
she is enriched she drinks from weaning or only
at the time of fertilization and
until birth  of the pups, that is to
say, with very little enrichment or
having already been raised in an
environment between enriched grown-ups,
so when the day of
adulthood arrived for all these individuals, which
again I repeat were both males and
females,
we did the different tests to
evaluate  their reproductive function and
then we performed
in vivo fertilization tests on the one hand in
which we placed
a control male in the females to evaluate the
females we placed a control male with
a control female with an
enriched female and an
enriched female from the moment of
fertilization, that is, from now on
we are going to call them enriched control females
and female  as
ep / enriched on day 1 of premier
on the other hand to the males while
we evaluate them by putting each male with two
control females with which
we double each evaluation of each male a little
and on the other hand to each male
also enriched with  two control females
in it
we are going to review specifically
that we evaluated in each male
we already said that we then put two
females for each male
and they were evaluated by performing in the
females those that were placed with the
males extended vaginal daily to
detect the moment of electro
presence  of spermatozoa or
vaginal plug that is in the
Álex Akular mouse produces a vaginal plug that
if one touches the vagina with the tip of a
yellow tip, those who are
used to the laboratory area
will know that they
can touch this plug at a cost  that is
produced and detect t over presence of
spermatozoa in the microscope and so
then we knew what was the day 1 of
premier d  In each of these females,
we then evaluated the body weight of the males, the
in vivo fertilization rate,
sacrificing the control female on the
17th day of premier, which we already knew when it
would be because we knew the day
this female had been awarded by  the
male and also the number of effects
also present in the male we evaluated the
testicular weight and the accessory glands
and different parameters of the
spermatic functional activity that were on the one
hand concentration that we evaluated
using this camera called
the maqellare camera that  It allows us to
evaluate the concentration of
spermatozoa that this animal has,
of course we obtained the
spermatozoa
after the sacrifice of the animal by
cervical dislocation or pardon for
decapitation and we obtained the
spermatozoa from the caudal epididymis
directly,
then we evaluated sperm motility
so that it is not in the subject, it means
that are motile are the
spermatozoa t  Also in
Claire's chamber we evaluate sperm vitality,
which means how many
are more or less in the sample, are
alive and viable using an
attention with gestures 33 2 in 58, which is
an attention that shows
blue sperm when they are
marked  While they look
transparent when they are alive,
we also evaluate the response of
the spermatozoon membranes to a
mototic type son to discomfort with a
computer solution in which this shows us,
let's say, the integrity or how
intact the spermatozoon membranes are.  and
on the other hand also the integrity
across or bad with a double staining of
spix and psa in which we observe the
spermatozoa that are with the
intact agrosoma in a fluorescent yellow color
this is very important because the next time
we do not know that they have to be intact
to  being able to fertilize and the different
stress conditions and others can
alter the reproductive function of
the a  sperm functional activity
then we evaluated
plasmatic concentrations of the patron text and
finally the behavioral response
before the minute in which a high or
plug
mail was carried out in males and
in females on the other hand we also carried
out daily marginal extensions
to detect the presence of spermatozoa in this
or vaginal plug
normally evaluating in a group of
females the body weight the uterine
and ovarian weight the rate of
spontaneous ovulation sacrificing the females
only when they were in
estrus and counting the oocytes we
knew when the female was ours
of course  Through the
daily vaginal smear in microscope
concentrations we evaluated
plasmatic concentrations of both
estradiol and progesterone and the
behavioral response to the
elevated plus maze, that is,
from feathers, doing it only
at the moment of right-handedness because, as
you will know
at the moment in which  that the animals
being in this can have
differential behavioral responses to
what the feather test is, therefore it is
extremely important to know that this
female is so skilled at our moment
in the group and we carry out
in vivo fertilization index evaluations
also seeing  the percentage of premier and the
size and weight of the chamber
in it
in the pups born from all these
experimental groups we also saw
on postnatal day 1 the litter that each
female had was reduced to eight pups 4 to 4
males with a total n of  40 pups
evaluated in total in each experimental group
because because we needed to
have a number of pups, let's say even
for reasons of nutrition of these
animals with respect to the current ones,
we made evaluations in these pups
of physical development on the one hand in
which we evaluated  body weight in the
arias body weight gain was one from birth 7 14 and 21
postnatal the day the animals  The males
had their eyes open as seen
in our photograph and after a few
days the animal will not only
grow its hair but also
its eyes will open, it will have an
eruption of the lower incisors
that was also evaluated and a
separation  of the pinna of the ear
as can be seen here
in the photograph that when they were just
born and as
development progresses with birth, these ears
separate from the body and this
indicates a little about the physical development
of the pups,
here we have the eruption  of the
incisors,
on the other hand, we also evaluated the
neurobiological development of the pups,
evaluating on the one hand the avoidance of
falling and on day 8 in which the pup is exposed to
the edge of a box in
height and is evaluated every day
at  starting practically a few days
after birth, it is forgiven on
day 8 after birth, it is
evaluated if that animal evades, that is, it
has the instinct to evade  the fall or it
will continue forward
the already negative geo tax is another of the
neurobiological parameters although
we evaluate what is
this that we have here
let's say if the animal is placed on an
inclined plane the animal has to be able
a parameter of its
neurobiological development is that the  animal is able
by itself to turn around and
go up in some way, let's say, to that
inclined plane
and finally what to make permanent
sends 9 after birth and
finally the righting reflex on the
surface that tells us when
giving birth  in a supine position if the
animal turns over by itself on
postnatal day 10,
we also finally evaluate the
reproductive development of these pups in pups,
seeing on the day of testicular descent, on the
day of separation, they go to the preputial and
on the day of vaginal opening in the
females vehicular access and separation
with the functional name of course in
males here we observe the closed vagina
and an open vagina s  And it is that you get
to see
and then here we have a fish in a
testicle in the calf with undescended testicles
and a calf with testicles
that have descended and that was a
daily evaluation starting from llamas
or less well at 12 postnatal
We then start with the results
of the males and the adult males
in this figure we can observe good
body weight at adulthood both males
raised in control conditions or
environmental enrichment since in
species that are in purple as you can see, we
did not find
significant differences in excesses
Then here we observe the testicular weight
and the accessory glands in this
case seminal vesicles and
we do not observe significant differences
at adulthood between males raised in
control conditions or enriched conditions
in this case we observe a summary of
what is precisely the sperm functional activity
sacral spermatozoa
then obtained from the epididymis of
that  s animals when they reach adulthood
and evidently we did not observe any
significant difference between
control animals and enriched animals either in
motility in vitality in which
membranes are intact or in how
intact the
in vivo fertilization rates are across or more
Pregnancy percentages were 90%
in both groups, both the control and the
enriched group. The number of fetuses
observed in the females fertilized
by control males or by
enriched males did not have significant differences,
nor did the
number of embryos of gene states that
is  a good indication of some reproductive failure
so now we turn to the results
of the females with respect to
body weight, in this case we also did not
find differences between
the control group and the enriched group,
we threw groups of animals had
groups of females had identical weight
bodily or reached adulthood with
identical person co
In this case, the interim weight and ovarian weight
did not show any significant differences.
The in vivo fertilization rates
were 100 percent in both
groups
and the spontaneous ovulation rate was
also no significant difference.
The spontaneous population rate
means that we continue  to the
females until the moment
of estrus and at this moment we
sacrificed the female and we saw how many
milestone votes we found in which
number of oocytes we found in the
ampulla
in this case we see the concentrations
of progesterone and estradiol while
in  the control group as in the
enriched group as in the aged
since weaning and we did not find significant differences
on the other hand if we found
significant differences between the three groups in
the size and weight of the litter
that is to say
the litter in the size and weight the
size and  litter size was
higher in the group of animals that
were e  nriched from weaning, on the other
hand, it was a little lower in the field in
the case of control animals or animals
enriched from the moment of
fertilization, how is it logical to think
of this other figure that I framed you,
we observed
the weight of the litter and in this case the
The weight of the litter does not present
significant differences, that is,
all the pups weighed the same if
then the number
of pups was higher in those
animals in those females that were
enriched from the weaning of their
species,
well in the case of the physical development of
these pups.  that we follow here we see the
evolution of the body weight
of the pups born to control mothers of
enriched on day 1 of premier, that
is, from fertilization or from
weaning and we can observe in this
figure what are male body prisoners
and in  In this case, the body weight
of the female and, as we can see, we do not observe
significant differences at any
moment of the growth with the natal of the
regarding the physical and
neurobiological development that we mentioned
previously, we could not detect
with levels of statistical significance
differences between the groups both for
the day of opening of the eyes of the separation
of the auricular pavilion or the day
of eruption of the incisors that these
are parameters  Physical and neurobiological parameters
also did not present
differences within the control in the
different experimental groups
if we observed an important trend and
here we observe in this figure what is
called a discriminant analysis of
different from these two parameters
of physical and neurobiological development of
the pups
and  We can observe that the offspring that
have been,
let's say, kept in
enrichment conditions from respect are
separated in some way in terms of
their physical and neurobiological development of
what the control females are and the
females are sorry, the control animals and
the y  animals that are enriched  s
from the moment that their mothers have been
enriched from the moment of
fertilization
in the male pups we observe Maria in
this figure the parameters of descents
to be stipulated in this case and the opening
of the bullet furrow in person and how
we can see
the other times  Male pups that were
reared by mothers who had been
enriched from the moment of
takeoff have testicular descent
closer or earlier than
control animals
, male pups differ significantly
in terms of testicular descent
, 100 percent is observed
We are going to clean and here we can observe
to clarify it a little more that 100
percent of the male pups had
enriched descent they had
testicular defense on day 21
while the females sorry the males the
control males reached one hundred
percent descent  testicular after the
23rd,
yes,
as far as what was the opening of the 5th
official value, we did not find any differences.
Significant differences
in the female offspring in their
reproductive development again 100 percent
of the females enrichment of the offspring
females raised by enriched mothers
from birth had faster
reproductive development,
that is, a
much faster vaginal opening than control animals,
reaching  having a vaginal opening
approximately on day 31 post
birth,
well with that, then we ended on the one
hand what was the experimental design 1,
the experimental design 2 was to follow that
effect 2, that is, to follow those pups that
we saw that apparently had a
physical development a  a little faster a
trend physical ministration a little
faster they also had
earlier sexual development the
enriched pups so we wanted to see
when these animals reached
adulthood what
their response would be in terms of reproductive physiology
so then we have the
experimental design that the pups  born in
experiment 1 e  n control or enriched conditions they
were maintained in the
conditions that their mothers at weaning age,
these animals were then
separated into groups of 5 individuals and
continued with the following
treatments for the same as their
mothers, that is, in control or
enriched conditions, therefore  In this case,
in this experiment we have animals that
have been enriched from
birth, not from weaning, but
from birth,
for fertilization, for the evaluation
of these animals, we once again perform
in vitro fertilization tests with an
identical godmother from experiment 1,
I'm going to you.  to name now what were
the parameters that we evaluated in these
pups when they reached adulthood they were
performed in the females extended
daily vaginal to detect again
this presence in other oil is another by
vaginal to estimate then the day of
premiere and see the index  of in vivo fertilization by
sacrificing those animals in the  day
17 of premieres again and the
behavioral responses to the la
benito en cruz elevated on the other hand in
the males the male pups we evaluated
again the fertilization index and live
weight testicular and
accessory glands professional activities
karma tics and
behavioral responses before
the cross elevated
We show some of the results at
this time and we see in this figure the
reproductive parameters in both males
and females, in this case we see the
number of fetuses of both males in the
different commissions and females in
the different connections of the sign is
that the male has  effects sign that
the offspring were forgiven by the females
fertilized by those males raised under
these conditions
in the case of the females if they were
fertilized by a control male and
then this is the evaluation of the
treatment there was no difference in the
number of fetuses that we found in
neither of the two treatments
and then see
the following figure  Using the same
conditions but this is the number of
degenerated embryos,
we did not observe
significant differences either, although the numbers
were much more variable in the
enriched conditions than in the
control conditions, but they did not reach
any level of significance.
So we are now going to observe the
results of the maze.  in cross celebrates
elevated or plus may of both experiment
1 and experiment 2 and we see what
we can observe then the percentage
of entries in males let's start with the
males we see the percentage of entries to
the workshop arms 2
the percentage
of time that we have the percentage  of
time that these animals spent in
open arms and the total number of
entrances into open arms as we can
see in
the males,
a decrease in  animals
that had been enriched
that  It means what
they know about in the plus mail. We can
say that the more time the
animals spend
in the greater number of entrances, those
animals have open arms, it
means that they have less
aversion to the test and therefore have
lower levels of  stress or anxiety
in reality that they present in a
new situation that is stressful for
a rodent such as being in an
open and unprotected space,
therefore here we see in the males that
the enriched males have a lower
percentage in these entrances to the
arms  open and therefore
indicates that these males would have
some conditions of greater aversion to the
text
or a little more anxiety before the test
than the control animals in terms
of females we only found
significant differences in the total number of
entries to the arms  open
that this indicates a little let's say the
wandering of the animals inside
what is the labyrinth in true  generator
and there we can see if the
enriched animals wandered much more
than the control animals in the text
this was the test that we did to the
parents, that is to say to the
f1 the animals that were enriched
from the southeast would come
while in  the young, that is to
say, the young when they reached
adulthood and we did the test of this
high level, those animals had been
raised in different conditions
since their birth, so here we can
see that
the significant differences were
also observed in the males only in
the  total number of entries, that is to say,
the enriched males presented a
higher percentage of greater total number
of entries to open arms, then
a greater wandering in the tec
again and in females, we observed if a
higher percentage of entry of jesper
where time they lost in open arms
to  the enriched animals, that is, in
this case, the animals indicate the
female control animals.  ra
behaved more anxiously before the
test, on the other hand,
the enriched females could
roam more freely in the test,
however, we also observed a large
number of has a greater number of
open arms entries
the total number of open arms entries
in these enriched females
lo  which again indicates a
greater emulation,
what we can observe mainly
in the males is that
and the enriched males demonstrated in adulthood
here we can see animals from
the control conditions and animals from
the enriched conditions and those
animals that were enriched
evidently presented
a great  aggression between them in which
the continuum of the cage
had bites, different signs or
marks of transsexual aggression, it
would be because they
had two males housed, this of
course was not observed in the females
as a conclusion, then we can say
that the use of environmental enrichment
had  a positive impact though  the noise
that was reflected in a greater number of
calves given birth by females reared under
these conditions since takeoff
, however this effect was not evident
when the animals were reared in
these conditions from birth
in males the addition of
enrichment
did not modify basic parameters  of their
reproductive physiology and however,
as described in other works, the
availability of resources that are,
let's say, appreciated in some way by
males causes an evident increase
in the levels of aggression
due to competition for the resource that occurs
much more in  the males that in the
females
a strong tendency is also observed
then to a faster natal development
in pups born under both
enrichment conditions both
from weaning and from day 1 of
pregnancy although
we could detect significant differences not only in
development parameters  reproductive in both
males and females
in conclusion and  In this
experimental model then if you plug in epa in
particular the use of
increased environmental complexity demonstrated
limited effects on reproductive physiology
and postnatal development
so let's go
thank you for taking part in this
conference and for your attention
so let's read if there are any questions
At the moment we don't have any
questions so if you want to ask any
questions this would be the moment for
me to answer them if you
write them on the left side of the
screen there is a box that says that a law
and there you can then put your
questions
m
and they ask us that it would be interesting to
know what would happen with other strains and if
we plan to do the same
experiments in another model if in fact
we wanted to test with waltz mice
that are eliminated for a while for a little
more use especially in what is
animal behavior so  we want to
repeat this experiment with another strain
of mouse and evidently  In this case, already
knowing that, above all,
adding tubes in which in males
causes greater aggression,
perhaps we would only use paper for the
construction of children and it would be a
next step.
Another question is what type of
enrichment do we use, there may be
people who  I have arrived a little later
to the presentation and so we repeat
that what we used was, we are going to go to the
beginning of the presentation, so I will show it,
we use these regular boxes of,
let's say, the standard dimensions of
a laboratory mouse box with the
addition of forgiveness  with the addition
of paper,
that is, the paper for the construction
of nests and pvc tubes so that the
animals could take refuge
well. Another question says what type of
enrichment in your experience is
best or definitely recommends, I
think that the ui course for the
bibliography also the use of
simply material for the
construction of nests is extremely
important I think it is the least
let's say in some way it has a
negative impact on the animals,
such as the
use of pvc tubes in males, the
pellet tubes that our criteria desires
were very useful in the case of
females because it was noticeable that the females
took refuge  A lot in these cubes was
a highly appreciated resource by the females,
since in the event of an
accidental flooding of the cage, for
example, the females would take refuge there for their
nest and their young and therefore they
managed to save them from whatever it
was.  an animation of the cages
but in the males if we observe
aggression it is precisely another of the
questions that tells us at what moments
the aggression is observed and we can say that
we began to notice this aggression
from the moment the
animals a few days after they  they already
began to have testicular descent
when the animals were almost
adults,
that is, testosterone levels,
as you know, are what  they somewhat dictate
the sexual maturity of the animal and that
is when the males come into
competition with
all the resources that they consider
appreciated and evidently the structure
of the tube was at least for what
is
usual conditions a
highly appreciated resource and then the group itself
let's say he was fighting for that resource and
obviously detrimental to the physical quality of these animals if the
males were to be housed
individually perhaps it could be
used there and it would be a question that we
have not tested but another question could be tested he
says he wanted to know if
enrichment may be advisable in
animals whose offspring are destined
for experiments with neuronal cultures
experiments with neuronal cultures
well actually it's something that I really
can't say too much because
we don't have experience but
obviously when we did
when we evaluated the neurobiological development of
the enriched offspring
we do not observe differences  Significant differences
in the offspring, the control and the
problem offspring, therefore we could
assume that at the neurobiological level,
aging does not have a
negative impact on my positive
if compared to the control, but that these
animals
have reached sexual maturity in a
faster is
definitely indicating that at the brain level
there is some kind of impact then it
would be a matter of evaluating again
I could not answer
more than them more than this
well the males
thank you Micaela for your greeting María
López asks if the males and
females are  they are housed in the same room or
in different areas he did not keep and
we kept both males and females in
the same room
but we were separated
in you
we can say that for the moment
while some
more questions are being asked
we can say no
not
in this direction ask
and in  that these results have not been
published yet so good,
anything, any question or consultation  If you
want to do anything about this subject, you
can do it directly to my personal email,
which I trust marina hotmail.com
marine function all together
that there is, I will gladly answer
any additional questions you may
have on this subject, surely we
intend to publish this study
during this year we will be able to  Getting them out
well Martel tells us
about which the director tells us is
a great presentation and thank you for
participating
thank you very much for inviting me to
give this videoconference and well if
we see if there is
our question carolina vega from the
university of chile
thank you very much for participating as well
Either in any question you
can ask us at a
private level with 100 marina at
hotmail.com and we are going to wait a few
more minutes
and this videoconference is over and I
hope it has been
good thank you very much then for
having participated since there are no more
questions  and see you at any
opportunity